this
is banned in kenya the government
stopped all contact sports
including football six months ago to
prevent the spread of covid19
but the kenyan premier league is hoping
for government permission to restart
next month
gord mahia football club has won it six
times in the last seven years
and the players are keen to prove
themselves again
so despite the ban they've resumed
training with some coved prevention
measures
if you can't play and the funds can't
come towards you so
it's it has been difficult and the
league had to be canceled so
we had to stay home and try and train
from home so it really affected us even
financially
the clubs did have no money not
only football has suffered because of
the covid restrictions
nearly two million kenyans have lost
their jobs
many from the poorest neighborhoods
where football is a popular pastime
community games like this one have
resumed in recent weeks
schools have been closed since march
there's not much to do
especially for young people the
coronavirus hasn't really caused the
kind of
major health crisis in kenya that people
feared might happen
relatively few people have become ill or
died compared to many other countries
and so the people here feel never mind
the rules
life and football must go on
the match organisers say it helps keep
school-aged children away from drug
abuse and crime
the league's clubs say they need to get
back in shape ahead of africa's
champions league
and qualifiers for the africa cup of
nations
here gorma are playing a friendly match
and it seems
nobody's stopping them two passing
police officers
stopped to watch the game i don't want
to say they're not enforcing it they are
enforcing it the fact that you are not
being caught you're trying as much as
possible
to comply and we see that it is right
now
that they do lift it and hopefully that
another
two days we should be prosecuted
for breaching the rules new covid rules
are expected to be announced on tuesday
the clubs and fans are hoping and
expecting that big games
will be allowed to kick off again
malcolm webb
al jazeera nairobi kenya